pour m'écouter la rue est appuyé sur 0,1
cloche zéro passe un truc là du tout là
c'est normal me suis foutu dehors je
[Rires]
[Musique]
suis monsieur ont dû danse dans
l'ascenseur d'un centre commercial et on
a piégé l'ascenseur l'ascenseur se
bloque un moment forcément vous appelez
le dépannage et quand le dépannage c'est
moi à merde c'est compliqué regardez
et hop un coup
elle
[Musique]
allô allô on n'évoquait pas l'identité
de la personne
tu me plais notre tour mag pourquoi
makoto prénom en fait d'un feu de c'est
le prénom jacques localiser rocher au
plaît merci c'est pas moi qui les ai
entendu qu il est censé ans commence à
voir des attaques et des blocs
[Musique]
construits en appel l'homme n'est pas
content de ma langue au téléphone on
m'appelle l'avenir spectacle qu'ils ont
pu et aurait pas ce qui est on avec moi
parce que je vais venir il ya des cas
qui vont tomber un bien mais il va voir
et de combinés mobiles
tu vas te calmer un nom quand je vais te
tirer les jours elle est rejetée
d'emblée si vous appuyez sur un cloche
attendez la fraîcheur des côtes ce que
je te dis ni les deux là les deux
bouffons là ils vont écouter la forêt
appuyés sur 0,1 cloche zéro passe un
truc à moi rien du tout là c'est normal
monsieur foot s'est pas enlevé sac à dos
a annoncé
j'aime aussi vous mettez le parterre le
plus aussi le plus non non non non s'ils
veulent quoi manger du groupe pour moi
n'est pas les 20 que j'adore les bas lui
même s'est contenté cette fois je la
prenais un petit quelque chose lors des
mois une chanson j'en ai tout de suite
parce que je vous aime bien où nous la
porte s'il te plaît vous on va te casser
les dents
chanter assez d'efforts il a fait un
effort je l'attendais bout si vous dites
on est deux gros bouffons vous dépendez
deux gros bouffons steuplé ouvre la
porte grand chef c'est moi c'est un gros
beauf on ouvre la porte blanche est
jamais que deux des clashs kit dernière
plus haut à huy pour réduire le poids
pour la senteur plus ok je sors c'est
sauter
[Musique]
c'est moi bon alors entre 3,5
le rapport cite hacker a reconnu c'est
un travail digne à tous et je t'offre un
cadeau de montfa royal on s'intéresse à
les deux bouffons à la loi du mec là qui
passe à la télé sur lauquet 0 pendant
des jours la tête de ma mère je voyage
si vous trouvez que je suis cyril
hanouna
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi vos reer a gagné presque
aussi qui fait de lui mais également
parce qu'il savait pas comment j'ai
[Rires]
testé un kit fin dans mon choix tu viens
avec moi
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]